happening now in North Las Vegas Clark
County students are performing in a
first of its kind event a mariachi
competition Joshua peguero stopped by
and spoke to Young Musicians today
each band at this inaugural event gets
about three minutes to tune their
instruments and then 13 to perform and
they hope to share their love of their
culture with the community Bailey Middle
School located along Hollywood and Carey
was among the first Mariachi groups
performing Saturday
foreign
well someone who was born in Guadalajara
is something really important to in my
culture so that's why I first started in
start to La Mariachi for those
unfamiliar with Mariachi and Ensemble
consists of musicians playing violins
trumpets and guitars this genre of music
dates back to at least the 18th century
performers also wear a Charro outfit
helping them gain a deeper understanding
of their Mexican culture I enjoy the
culture way more than I did before
because I know how hard the people used
to work for it they also spend hours
practicing before they hit the stage
learning life skills that goes beyond
music when you practice every day when
you tell them to show up on time tell
them to be well dressed make sure you
comb your hair you're teaching
professionalism five judges will pick
the top winners awarding cash prizes the
city of North Las Vegas is behind this
competition hoping to keep students
engaged while recognizing its large
Hispanic population sometimes we're
selected as negative individuals in the
community this showcases the beauty that
we bring to the community everybody
understands what music is it's it's an
international language organizes Hope by
hosting this event other schools in
Clark County will adopt Mariachi
programs in their curriculum reporting
at Craig Ranch Regional Park Joshua
peguero eight news now